hey what's up everybody
Oh welcome to this week's episode of
megabit I'm here at my buddy Benito
how's it going we've got two new
Dreamcast games if you can believe that
brand-new Dreamcast games yeah a couple
of brothers out in Germany have been
busy making some arcade style shooters
for the Dreamcast for the past few years
and each one of them after working in
tandem has just released a game of their
own and so we're gonna show you two of
those today and one of the games that
used to work on the first one we're
gonna start with is neo X Y X and this
is a side-scrolling shooter or a
vertical one they actually made it so
you can change it depending on your
preference we're gonna play as a
side-scrolling shooter today these games
are really difficult especially pretty
cool it's like a side-scrolling uh jeez
it's a side-scrolling like action
platformer
damn big horrible um what Peter costume
anyway yeah well you sent me some
questions for the from the chat and
we'll try to start that yep Bob Jones
says are super-nice versions of an what
does that mean okay and you know and a
dot mmm
okay Bob what are you talking about
yeah Bob yeah Bob what's this am yeah
Bob you can't just drop names that
explain yourself okay
and really elaborate bitmaps and it's
really challenging but the other games
that these guys have worked on bear a
closer resemblance to something like our
type a little bit more slower paced this
one is really just impressive for a lot
of reasons like the speed the graphics
it's very difficult as well but it looks
really nice but these guys are like
hardcore you know longtime shooter fans
you know the fact that this is
challenging is kind of a good sign
that's what these games are made they're
made to be is really difficult and not
just because there are bullets
everywhere but it's supposed to really
challenge your reflexes it's you know
typically you'd be playing this you know
by yourself like hyper focused oh forget
it really when they started doing
lockouts
so you can buy cart conversion adapters
that allow you to play arcade games on
your home system your home Neo Geo if
you want to save some money but for
later games that were released like mark
of the ball or actually keen of Fighters
2000 I think was one of the first ones
that I really have you handed with the
detection of locking out so what happens
is if you use one of those conversion
carts like a cheap one you'll see it
like really bad artifacting and sprite
scaling and a really horrible sound
quality so you'll pay a couple hundred
bucks for a good converter and even then
even then those are hard to come by
they're not produced in mass quantities
okay I'm gonna start over and do this
more seriously like a dollar in this
game oh I'm a dollar in and I'm gonna
switch the perspective on this and play
a vertical how would you compare this to
like you know the next gen stuff like
let's say wrestle then how would I
compare it yeah and within which I mean
I'd say it's just as good factor fun
fact well we're doing fun factory oh man
something will game pro abuse oh yeah no
just as good just as solid a blob don't
ask me have you played Schneider r2
Schneider arcade no I'm not what is that
Bob Jones Bob
throwing out these random game titles
that I want to say this boss is in the
same boss that I fought here and I was
playing in a different perspective it's
got the same bullet patterns but it
looks different you got the top view I
know but like the lighting is even
larger
it's called o makki mode
and sometimes the stuff comes down to
you know like recognizing certain
enemies and remembering their patterns
yeah yes sure but uh it's also reflex
timing and I was arguing or Emmel in the
office and people couldn't really wrap
their head around what I was saying but
it's one of the only games we're outside
of boss fights you actually need to
shoot enemies I could get through this
this game just avoiding bullets until I
get to a boss right
thus in amaura you're constantly running
out of time and you only earn time by
shooting enemies let's say you have to
yeah so you have to and I was trying to
explain it to people in the office
they're like no like you know like space
of games like our type you have to shoot
enemy so I'm like hey buddy you don't
have a score and people did not I was
not allowed to put that argument in my
review because I wasn't able to convince
really any for save dance I had that was
another scenario - you were like not
that many people really got why I
thought that game is so great and it's
even got an insane narrative tomorrow
yeah with really dark like under
undercurrents of of just the worst of
humanity represented in furry form so my
problem with Smurfs when I play them is
that I tend to conserve bombs and not
use them to protect yeah me too yeah
blow down but that slowdown helps you
out especially these two helps you out
and what's crazy is that all the modern
shmups made by things like cave they
build in slow down and so when you play
a console port sometimes it doesn't have
that slowdown and fans get upset running
it for at before what you think that's
cool weird
yeah the opposite problem the word we're
using is shmups which is short for
shoot-'em-ups
their most recent pop has gotta be soon
tomorrow by far up refrozen what
happened yeah
that's God telling us to change the game
and that's called Redux Dark Matters do
do art and this one is nate is let's see
this one was done by Renee Helwig the
last one was headed up by 10 his brother
man I was like training before you got
started and I was like cool I'll be just
fine it's a way different than cameras
on you he's just sort of my that
opportunity for me to play something I
care about so I don't know what these
guys are doing
they're like they're not hurting it
doesn't hurt but that's not giving you
points is it for me I maybe have a look
strange hitbox it's like only in your
ass only in my ass hit your ass you're
dead I keep all my stuff cool so the
next game we're gonna play last hope
it's actually the version called last
hope pink bullets they rereleased the
game with pink bullets as they implies
because it was so hard to tell what was
friendly and what was enemy [ __ ] uh
what's what's bad and what's not alright
oh great man
I can't come of those extra lives Bob
Jones is asking if we gonna pick Game
Boy games I doubt that oh we're going to
play game ball games how would we do
that
this is with the gameboy player on the
Gamecube oh yeah next week I'm either
gonna play because I've been waiting to
play NHL 94 with Tom McShea that's one
of my favorite Jenner oh my god that's
so good I had a super nest that is so
good is one of my favorite games of all
time Genesis yeah that game is on me but
I also kind of want to play the Game Boy
Color version of Metal Gear Solid next
week to celebrate the release of ground
zeroes which is that game is so strange
it's some people probably know it
referred to as a ghost Babel but
essentially it's a retelling of the
middle your solid story but it like
changes up the plot it's super strange
but it looks really really good for a
Game Boy game and the animation is
actually really nice it's probably bout
time we switched to the last game anyway
you can see I can rotate that Potter on
my ship obviously you really do need a
stick though you're gonna do it that way
I'm not gonna play that way but that is
a way that you can I feel that stick the
pad thing should be a switch on the pad
it should be pretty right
and I should get on it Sega yeah go back
in time and get your ship is not me
really quick very fast at all that's
it's just a Walter that's one thing
about shmups man like the rules change
between every yeah
like searching between them like you you
train yourself to like it's like okay I
can hit the wall if I need to or like
don't hit the wall man excuse me yeah so
this is the new game and this was this
one's done by the two of them businesses
yeah this was there
this was their joint project from a
while back
so just to recap those last two games
were done by like one brother each yeah
they joined forces to make this one yeah
this isn't going so well Bonita doesn't
it like it
oh I found us some cheat codes you did I
think so what's it from good old game
facts oh they didn't have any trick they
don't yeah they have a page that's not
that good I see right now they're these
little tiny little like flies coming up
oh that's not see this the trusty though
innit I reading this for him to find our
codes for this game everybody like the
first guys like it cold service very but
everybody's like it doesn't fit it
continues what do you care doesn't I
wish I could stop sucking okay this side
just turn this room so like why do you
want to treat because this game is
ridiculously hard but it's got cool
content right and you like that's the
like you want to get further into it so
just uh yeah uh sometimes you don't want
to go in this game for fifteen hours so
he's got this little vacuum sphincter
down there it's trying to pull me in
they try to pull you it yeah you'll see
it well so I mean for a lot of those old
systems we can actually do is like pick
up collections for ps2 and Xbox that
have like you know it but come on game
it's not the same is playing with like
that it's not the same it's a lot easier
to to make happen
[ __ ] it is a less you want anyway I
would be the one complaining if you have
to do that one I want to play title
legends to at some point pretty soon
that's got a lot of really title legends
it's got a lot of guys made I call these
shmups right infinite continues that's
why I heard [ __ ] [ __ ] oh and
keep in mind too we're playing this game
essentially got a hard mode because
we're not taking advantage of the
rotatable unit on the frontier ship
again you can but it's it's hard about
these controls yeah it's a lot easier
when you have the regular Dreamcast
things you can just use oh yeah oh those
things are invisible
those pink okay so more pink bullets
last okay yeah even more now it's even
more pink all-pink books and then it's
too much pain can get a really some new
ones like okay less pink sorry guys
bullet hell is a very specific man is a
very specific sub-genre where
essentially this screen will be filled
with bullets any point in time to where
it slows the system down and you
literally have pixels to move between
these bullets it's a you know sure a lot
of shmups have a lot of projectiles
coming at you
but unless it has what I was just
describing just like it's curtain of
bullets it's not technically bullet hell
but not a lot of people subscribe to
that rule but that's actually the where
it came from
there's so many old games out there but
I want to play thank you all I did put
this up above don't I got it you got it
off now I'm all about doing like a daily
lunch scream on my own channel I don't
know what just like random just random
old games yeah just like lo-fi
production yeah cuz it's crazy I can
think of every game people are
interested mentioning I want to play
I'll see you guys in two weeks from
other episode of mega bit I'm gonna play
NHL 94 with Tom McShea it's gonna happen
play for place we should play if we can
all right thanks for shooting at
everyone but you know thank you for
joining me sure take care of you got
everybody fights you later